IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THEIR BATTLE FOR 2020 IS
OFFICIALLY ON AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
HOLD HIS FIRST CAMPAIGN RALLY IN
EL PASO, TEXAS, TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT TAKING AIM AT
DEMOCRAT BETO O'ROURKE FOR
HOLDING A COUNTER RALLY IN THE
CITY AS HE MAKES HIS BIG PUSH
FOR BORDER SECURITY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO EL PASO.
WE HAVE A LINE THAT IS VERY LONG
ALREADY.
YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
I UNDERSTAND OUR COMPETITORS GOT
A LINE TOO BUT IT'S A TINY
LITTLE LINE.
THEY WILL MAKE IT SOUND LIKE
THEY HAD MORE PEOPLE THAN WE DO.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE ARE GOING THERE FOR A REASON.
WE'RE GOING THERE TO KEEP OUR
COUNTRY SAFE.
>> Jesse: THE FIELD OF
DEMOCRATIC CONTENDERS GETS MORE
CROWDED.
TRUMP MOCKING ELIZABETH WARREN
FOR THE DNA DEBACLE HANGING OVER
HER CAMPAIGN ANNOUNCEMENT.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO POKING FUN AT
SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR FOR
ANNOUNCING HER CANDIDACY IN A
SNOWSTORM.
WARREN FIRING BACK AGAINST THE
PRESIDENTS ANCESTRY ATTACKS.
>> BY THE TIME WE GET TO 2020,
DONALD TRUMP MAY NOT EVEN BE
PRESIDENT.
IN FACT, HE MAY NOT EVEN BE A
FREE PERSON.
>> Jesse: KLOBUCHAR ADDRESS
FROM REPORTS SHE CAN'T FIND A
CAMPAIGN MANAGER BECAUSE SHE'S
DIFFICULT TO WORK FOR.
>> I AM TOUGH.
I PUSH PEOPLE.
THAT IS TRUE.
BUT MY POINT IS THAT I HAVE HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FOR MYSELF.
I HAVE HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR ME, AND I
HAVE HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: KAMALA HARRIS MAKING
HEADLINES TODAY FOR THIS
COMMENT.
>> HAVE YOU EVER SMOKED?
>> I HAVE.
AND I INHALED.
I DID INHALE.
[LAUGHS]
IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO.
>> WAS AT A BLONDE OR JOINT?
>> IT WAS A JOINT.
>> SO IF IT WAS LEGALIZED ALL
THROUGH THE COUNTRY.
>> I THINK IT GIVES A LOT OF
PEOPLE JOY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: GREG, WE WILL GET TO
THAT IN A SECOND BUT YOU AND AMY
KLOBUCHAR HAVE A LOT IN COMMON.
VERY DIFFICULT TO WORK WITH.
>> Greg: I LIKE HER MORE AND
MORE THE MORE I HEAR ABOUT IT.
I LIKE HER NAME.
KLOBUCHAR.
SHE HAS A 1970s COP SHOW NAME.
CAN I TALK ABOUT, AND ALSO IT'S
NOT SEXIST TO POINT OUT THAT
SHE'S GOT A BAD TEMPER.
THEY DO THAT WITH JOHN McCAIN
AND THEY DID WITH BOB DOLE AND
THEY DO IT WITH TRUMP.
IT AIN'T SEXIST.
IT'S SEXIST NOT TO DO IT.
DO YOU HAVE TAPE OF LIZ WITH THE
KIDS?
>> Jesse: YES.
ELIZABETH AND ONE OF HER
ANNOUNCEMENTS THIS WEEKEND.
>> Greg: GET OVER HERE, KID.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH LIZ
WARREN.
SHE IS LIKE A PROFESSIONAL
WRESTLER WHO OVER ACTS IN EACH
SCENE AND THEN INSTRUCTS YOU TO
BELIEVE IN THE SPORT OF MATTER
WHAT.
SHE'S A POLITICIAN WHO PRETENDS
TO BE A POLITICIAN WHEREVER SHE
GOES AND IT IS SO FAKE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE ERA OF TRUMP
WHERE HE REJECTED ALL OF THAT,
ALL THE TRIMMINGS OF BEING A
POLITICIAN, HE DIDN'T CARE.
IT EXPOSES HER FOLLY EVEN MORE
AS A WORLD-CLASS PHONY.
SHE'S A PROFESSIONAL WRESTLER
AND YOU SEE ALL THE TRICKS.
GRAB THIS KID.
AND THEN SAYING, WHAT DID SHE
SAY?
HE WON'T BE A FREE PERSON.
JUST A FREE MAN.
SAVE A SYLLABLE.
>> Jesse: KLOBUCHAR AND WE
ALSO HAVE KAMALA HARRIS
ADMITTING TO SMOKING WEED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Kennedy: I THINK IT MAKES
HER A TOTAL HYPOCRITE.
CONVENIENTLY SHE'S ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO'S HOPPED ON BOARD THE
CANNABIS CARAVAN.
BUT IN REALITY, PEOPLE IN HER
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
SUFFERED UNDER SOME OF HER
PUNITIVE ACTIONS AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SHE EVEN CACKLED A FEW YEARS AGO
WHEN ASKED ABOUT LEGALIZATION OF
CANNABIS IN THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO HAS NOT
SUPPORTED LEGALIZATION.
SHE HAS LOCKED UP A BUNCH OF
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS AND HAS NOT
LOBBIED FOR THEIR RELEASE WHEN
SHE COULD HAVE.
SHE MISSED USED HER POWER.
SHE WAS HORRIBLE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS AND RIGHT NOW IT'S A
POPULARITY GRAB.
WHO WOULDN'T CACKLE WITH
AFFECTION AT MY FRIEND
CHARLEMAGNE.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE ANOTHER
REASON TO VOTE FOR KAMALA.
SHE SMOKES GRASS.
>> Juan: I WAS TELLING YOU.
--
LOOK, I DON'T THINK THAT WAS THE
THING YOU SAID.
>> Kennedy: FACTS NOT
FEELINGS.
>> Juan: HANG ON, PLEASE.
ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT WAS HER JOB AS AN OFFICER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ENFORCE THE LAW, NOT MAKE IT OU
OUT.
>> Kennedy: SHE SELECTIVELY
ENFORCED LAWS AND WAS HORRIBLE
ON CIVIL --
>> Juan: THAT'S THE LAW.
YOU HAVE TO ENFORCE IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO GO AFTER HER ON
CHARGES OF SELECTIVE PROSECUTION
ARE WAY OFF ON THIS.
IT'S ALMOST TO ME, AND THIS
COMES FROM THE LEFT MORE THAN
THE RIGHT, THEY ARE SAYING
BECAUSE YOU ARE A GOOD
PROSECUTOR YOU CAN'T BE
DEMOCRATIC.
HOW CRAZY IS THAT?
>> Kennedy: DON'T CALL
YOURSELF A PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTOR IF YOUR RECORD SHOWS
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE.
>> Juan: SHE WAS A VERY GOOD
PROSECUTOR.
ANYWAY, I WILL LEAVE THAT UP TO
YOU.
I WILL SAY I THINK THE NEWS
TODAY IS ABOUT TRUMP IN EL PASO
BECAUSE OUR OWN BRAIN ROOM THAT
YOU LIKE TO CITE, JESSE, HAS
SAID VIOLENT CRIME WASN'T HIGHER
BEFORE THE WALL IN EL PASO.
>> Jesse: SO GLAD YOU BROUGHT
THAT UP, JUAN.
>> Juan: I WANTED TO BRING
THIS UP BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
SHAM.
>> Jesse: NO, IT'S NOT.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
IN 2009 WHEN THE WALL WAS
ERECTED IN EL PASO, ABOUT 3300
VIOLENT CRIMES REPORTED.
THE LAST AVAILABLE YEAR,
STATISTICS WERE OUT, 2016, ABOUT
2600 VIOLENT CRIMES REPORTED.
THAT'S ABOUT A 20% DROP IN
VIOLENT CRIME SINCE THE WALL HAS
BEEN ERECTED IN EL PASO.
JUAN, I'M SORRY.
NOT ONLY DO YOU DISAGREE WITH
ME.
YOU ARE DISAGREEING WITH THE
BRAIN ROOM.
>> Juan: THIS IS WHY HE
MENTIONED IT.
YOU HAD PLAYED THIS FARCICAL
GAME BEFORE AND SO I WENT TO THE
BRAIN ROOM AND THEY SAID FROM
2006 TO 2011, VIOLENT CRIME --
I'M NOT CHERRY PICKING.
>> Jesse: THERE WAS NO WALL IN
2006.
IT WAS WHEN IT WAS APPROPRIATED.
WHY STOP AT 2011?
>> Juan: WE CAN GO ALL THE
WAY.
YOU CAN GO ALL THE WAY.
>> Jesse: I DID.
FROM WHEN THE WALL WENT OFF
UNTIL LAB -- WENT UP UNTIL THE
LAST AVAILABLE YEAR.
>> Juan: YOU ARE WRONG AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO FOOL THE
AUDIENCE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WRONG.
>> Juan: BETO O'ROURKE, THE
SHERIFF IN EL PASO, THE MAYOR IN
EL PASO ALL SAY THIS TOWN HAD A
LOW CRIME RATE BEFORE AND AFTER
THIS PHONY WALL.
>> Jesse: I WILL PUT THE STATS
ON MY TWITTER FEED AND EVERYONE
CAN SEE THE TRUTH.
>> Morgan: WE ARE DEFINITELY
GOING TO SOLVE THIS TODAY SO I'M
SO GLAD WE'RE HAVING IT.
WE HAD MORE WOMEN ANNOUNCE OVER
THE WEEKEND AND I THINK WE HAVE
AT LEAST FIVE SO FAR THAT ARE
RUNNING.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED ON THE
DEMOCRAT SIDE AND THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE IS THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN ONE
WOMAN ON STAGE.
THERE'S BEEN ALL THESE RULES,
THE SENATORIAL RACE IS IN
PRESIDENTIAL RACES ABOUT HOW DO
YOU APPROACH THE ONE WOMAN ON
THE STAGE.
NOW THAT WE HAVE FOUR OR FIVE,
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW THE DEMOCRATS PLAY IT.
HOW THEY ARGUE WITH EACH OTHER.
I THINK IT'S A REALLY -- IT'S
GOING TO BE AN INTERESTING
ELECTION TO SEE THE INTERACTION,
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN THE WOMEN.
CAN WE PREEMPT THIS CATFIGHT
NARRATIVE THAT PEOPLE MAGAZINE
AND "US WEEKLY" WILL PUT OUT,
THESE WOMEN ARE GOING TO BATTLE
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE TOUGH
AND THEIR POLITICIANS AND THEY
WANT TO BE THE PRESIDENT.
>> Kennedy: CAN I SAY ONE
THING ABOUT KLOBUCHAR.
I WAS INTRIGUED THAT SHE IS
TOUGH ON HER STAFF.
I DIDN'T TAKE THAT AS A NEGATIVE
AT ALL.
>> Greg: YOU ARE KNOWN FOR
BEING VERY TOUGH.
>> Kennedy: VERY TOUGH.
I AM PRACTICALLY A DOMINATRIX.
PEOPLE PAY ME FOR MY SERVICES.
>> Greg: THE ONE THING ABOUT
THIS WHOLE THING THAT IS SO
BEAUTIFUL AND WHY THIS IS GOING
TO BE THE BEST TWO YEARS EVER,
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A FIELD OF
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES.
WE HAVE ONGOING DIRECTOR'S
COMMENTARY FROM DONALD TRUMP.
THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
THE PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO DO
ONGOING COMMENTARY.
HIS MEDIA PRESENCE IS SO HUGE
THAT BY COMPARISON, THEY WILL
SEEM SO SMALL.
HE WILL BE DARTH VADER AND THEY
WILL BE EWOKS.
>> Juan: OVER THE WEEKEND, HE
WENT OVER AFTER KLOBUCHAR AS
SNOWMAN OR SNOW WOMAN.
SHE SHOT BACK.
I WANT TO SEE YOU OUT IN THE
RAIN WITH YOUR HAIR.
I THINK YOU DODGED --
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW IF SHE
SAID THAT.
>> Juan: SHE SAID IN RESPONSE
IN HER TWEET THAT HE IS THE ONE
WITH SENSITIVE HAIR.
IF HE GOES AFTER THOSE WOMEN, I
THINK THEY FIRE BACK.